[Music]
hi everyone my name is Vegas
I'm from dansk and I've come to these
igniting talks today to just tell you
about simple plugins that I developed
for ontology platform so this is kind of
related to pycharm as well because it's
all the same family so the problem I
encountered was I was writing a project
quite a big one
it's not that but it was similar so I
was working for a very long time about a
month so - ie spent I think in total an
hour to drag all the windows of pycharm
in the order that I like so I really
prefer 80 why 80 characters long columns
for the code and I wanted for everything
else including console and the project
structure to be on the right side so
that was pretty neat I could do all that
but then terrifying thing happened I
imported my project on my laptop from
the desktop computer and the layout
window I layout was gone everything I
spent my time when I couldn't start
working because it was so annoying so I
thought hey probably jetbrains already
have something ready for that turns out
not not even a plug-in for that so I was
terrified by the idea of developing a
plugin for that platform it's down it's
Java payment so but I still did that
because I felt that there is a use case
for that so what it does is it allows
you to export current window layout I
don't see anything let me check it so
yeah basically you click on the window
and I hope you can see it you can export
the way out to some XML file and you can
import it back so
I can show it right now because I really
can click the button I don't see it but
yeah it's as easy as that
so feel free to check out this plugin
there is a github page about it yep just
sick
oh yeah so right it just addresses the
problems that you might face when you
are working on different machines with
the same project in PyCharm and you want
your layout to be preserved thank you
[Applause]
you